how do you stop caring what other people
think
what do you guys think
actually never mind I was a very happy
child just a ball of Joy running around
talking to any stranger asking them to
be friends
just being myself
until the incident happened and things
changed I went from being this happy
Carefree child to being very
self-conscious I can actually resonate
with that a little bit dude I remember
my mom passed away I went through like a
bunch of old like VHS tapes and I would
look at these videos of myself running
around like going up to people all the
time like just like not caring
I had no idea I was like I used to be
that way I just run around and like go
to people and so my friend Hunter and I
you may have seen him in some previous
Adventures wanted to figure out how do
we get back to not giving a flippy have
you ever heard of exposure therapy well
Hunter hasn't either it's uh not for
everyone
but I thought we'd both really benefit
from it I spend too much time thinking
about how I'm gonna be perceived it's
like I'm so aware of it you get kind of
Trapped in your mind right on the
outside you're smiling and talking but
on the inside you kind of feel really
lonely especially in big groups of
people once it gets to six eight people
I'm just not gonna say much I don't want
to be the person that's just kind of
like oh yeah it's Hunter like Hunter's
around he's here too I guess like I want
to be someone like actually contributes
to conversation it's gotten like so bad
and I haven't done anything about it why
don't we do that
[Music]
what do you mean
what if we just go out and do some fun
dares we start small and it'll continue
to get more difficult over time we'll
make it a game whoever quits first has
to wear an adult diaper for 24 hours and
just go about their normal day you down
uh I don't want to like look back on my
life and be like damn like I never
really did anything about that
so we got to Jake collini with us the
master of not giving a flip how do I not
give a freak I don't know man and just
kind of be myself and if people don't
like it that's their problem you don't
want to be my friend it's freshman my
password
I feel like a big part of that just just
knowing yourself you just got to know
you and you gotta be cool with you
what's up YouTube we're out here in
Austin Texas
if I'd do some challenges let's start
off with something simple I dare you to
get a high five from a stranger high
five
yes it's your turn
no
come on Hunter you can do it oh he's
hesitating
just go
that couldn't have been more Awkward
ever it is good it was good I know you
like to strive for Perfection so I
challenge you to talk to a stranger in
10 seconds starting right now
how's it going
you just uh
hanging out
yeah I just finished the run and walk if
you come and run here a lot would you
say you're a perfectionist oh yeah 100
yes especially when it comes to making
videos for sure every stage of it I'm
trying to perfect like oh thinking once
again yeah I think this whole thing of
not caring too much about what other
people think a lot of it comes down to
knowing who you are yeah no I I 100
agree and I feel like I've
been questioning that a lot lately I was
making like content that's like super
serious and oh my God that's not who I
am like I like to be silly and have fun
like make jokes it makes me nervous to
like do those things but I think it's a
big part of who I am I think that's what
it comes down to if you know who you are
and you love yourself and you accept
yourself the way you are that creates so
much Freedom nice to meet you Bob have a
good one hey Mr social how did it go I
was so nervous about that because he
just like did not seem into it at all I
felt like an app going up to him hey man
this next deer is much more challenging
you walk up to someone about to fist
bump them and then last second you
switch to a handshake and you shake
their fists and after that you invite
them to your Workshop
thank you
that sounds awful this one looks fun you
want to do it oh yeah I would love to do
this yes how's it going
oh sorry hey would you have any interest
in going to my workshop
like a dogs
this bomb
uh come on
get out of your head sorry it's just a
it's just a joke ah hey dude how's it
going
how you doing what's your name oh sorry
that's so awkward I'm sorry I'm running
a workshop I want to invite some people
uh maybe you'd be interested hello you
clearly didn't help with that now are
you ready
oh my God
it's gone
I'm sorry
funny is I'm hosting a workshop oh my
God I think for everyone there is this
incident that happens as a child you
just love no matter what until you reach
a certain age and you're crying and all
of a sudden your parent doesn't just
immediately come to you that's one of
the earliest memories that I have dude
is literally being a kid my dad came in
picked up Drayden and took Drayden like
into the bed I remember like waking up
and seeing that happen like walking in
being like hey I want to get into bed
too like my dad was like hey no like go
to sleep like drain your brothers crying
I remember going back and just like
bawling being like what this is the
incident for you that incident changed
you forever what was the meaning of this
for for little Hunter
yeah that I wasn't loved yeah yeah I
feel like I wasn't
um
as important
[Music]
I'm so surprised I still remember it
just oh yeah usually the earliest memory
that we have is our first trauma your
brain your entire system remembers
because that's the first time fear
entered your body yeah and all of a
sudden you're like there are certain
conditions that are tied to my love and
there always is and that's when you
start thinking about what do people
expect who do I need to be for my dad
who do I need to be for my mom for me it
was my birthday and my parents were
fighting before they got finally
divorced and I asked them hey can you
please stop fighting it's my birthday
and they just ignored me I think at that
point I started believing that I have to
look after myself because I can't trust
them who did you have to be for your dad
in order to be loved
even now it's tough dude yeah it's very
very tough yeah yeah
a lot of expectations yes yeah
gosh man that's so uncomfortable like
again I'm like I just being a dick and
people are getting upset because they've
got things to do but I think now would
be a good time to bring out the fot
machine you have a fart machine remote
controlled Thought Machine which means
I'm gonna be controlling flatulence from
a distance
yeah
are you okay sir
[Music]
oh
beautiful day yeah
well I gotta get going
at this point Jake's just doing it off
camera how's it going
I dare you to lie down in public
[Music]
trees are not good stop planting trees
guys when you start crossing the road
you have to like start doing a crab walk
there's so many people here
I dare you to walk up to someone and ask
them to borrow 100 bucks
hey guys I lost my wallet I have to
borrow a few dollars don't believe what
the government tells you it's gonna fall
out yes I was wondering if I could
borrow 100 bucks for gas money it's an
ATM or I could then know you guys I know
no
[Music]
there's for me at the end of the day it
doesn't get really bad or what you do as
long as you're having a good time
yeah I know I'm good I'm just just
chilling
seems surprisingly confident at doing
this and like doing these challenges now
I feel significantly more comfortable
doing it I feel like I've built up that
tolerance to it where now it's just like
okay here we go again I would love you
to try something genuine because it's
easy to just play a character and do
silly things but really putting yourself
out there and really saying who you are
what you struggle with I think that
could be a good challenge now I've
actually got to go up and like
show my personality and
yes how's it going
Hunter
so I'm trying to approach new people we
put together
a little survey for people that are
close to you wow dude okay just to write
down some things that they love about
you most and also something that they
think you could improve on something
they maybe even dislike about you are
you a little worried but you're gonna
definitely yes especially like depending
on who you asked there's so many things
but the thing I love most about Hunter
is he doesn't just do what's easy he
does what's right quitting College when
his mom passed away would have been easy
but pushing through and graduating to
honor his mom and to show himself he
could do it that was right Hunter is an
incredibly noble man it's easy to be
around because he'll always tell you
what he's feeling and basically never
gets angry or frustrated even when it's
completely warranted
damn dude
I'm trying to go out
to people you know I'm not the best at
like
socializing and stuff like that I get
I don't get anxious about it all right
what is the biggest area of improvement
for Hunter Hunter is 100 a perfectionist
when it comes to his work and what he
contributes to social situations give
less and understand that perfect doesn't
exist like who said that wait a minute
wait a minute
yeah you as well all right it's a
pleasure sir it's like I know who I want
to be I trade my brother his tick tocks
the ridiculous dude been it like a lot
of the times conflicts with the views
that my dad has I even talked to him the
other day and told him I was like yeah
like I want to start putting more comedy
in my videos and he was like yeah you
need to like watch out for great and
some of the jokes that he makes in his
videos like the comedy is just it's not
him it's not who he is I didn't say
anything but I'm like no that's actually
exactly who he is it's just not who you
want him to be he's a phenomenal dad but
it I do feel like that pressure just to
be
like the absolute best not everyone is
close with their siblings but my brother
is my best friends
[Music]
so kind
like does anything that other people
think matter if you have these people
around you like if you think about it
[Music]
you thought this was over hey maybe I
have one more day for you I dare you to
do five minutes of open mic stand up
with me tomorrow at 8pm
open mic stand up it's like stand-up
comedy I'm terrified too this is like
literally my biggest fear I mean you
don't have to you can just wear the baby
costume go grocery shopping just go
about your normal day you know probably
gonna stay up all night trying to think
of jokes I was like 13 at the time and I
was like running for student council
like I went up in front of like the
entire school and gave the speech
remember it's like getting like this
full panic attack like shaking and
stuttering if you gave a speech as you
now would you be worried that that would
happen again oh yeah 100 yes I have
absolutely nothing prepared I have my
material ready it's terrible I have only
one hour left to rehearse it I've spent
like the past few hours just writing
some ideas for stand-up jokes I don't
know if they're funny or not
I'm finding myself trying to perfect it
and I you know having really high
expectations on how it should go but I
think the goal should just be to not
judge myself and still find a way to
enjoy it I feel like I'm gonna go up
there and just embarrass myself in front
of a lot of people
I am ready are you
okay me neither we're leaving in 10
minutes God damn it
this is crazy dude are you ready
no I mean we had 24 hours yes dude like
that's nobody's gonna have high
expectations but still like oh they will
they paid money to be here
that's how you got to think mindset
they're gonna be so pissed oh no
the audience
it's you
good luck buddy to you dude
hello ladies and gentlemen so glad you
came out how's everybody doing
finish too early as usual
you know being German is a life sentence
I've never ending shame and guilt we
have like
oh you know the word gift in German
means poison that led to some weird
situations with my girlfriend she was
like wouldn't it be cute to give our dog
a gift this Christmas that relationship
didn't last really long
um you did a great crowd this is it
I want to introduce my friend Hunter who
is a professional comedian
amazing show
[Music]
I do not want to do this at all right
now I did not want to be here
you know I'm doing this video with Leon
and how to stop giving a [ __ ]
and Leon he's an expert in not giving
him seriously yeah he has a five years
absolute Pro absolute Pro I'm pretty
anxious about this but I get kind of
anxious and a lot of social situations
like even when I go to Chipotle they
they ask too many questions and I try to
like please the employee with what I
ordered you know what I mean a lot of my
friends are doing better than I am
let me borrow a 600 shirt I was like
yeah I don't know if I'm comfortable
wearing my net worth we go out and I'm
just like a mustard drop away from
declaring bankruptcy
nice I feel like we could just keep
going like this with a Dez but I won't
dare you again I'll just stand over
there again ever the fact that is
Concord one of my biggest fears like
means so much to me like it's gonna
carry over to like a lot of things so
seriously thank you so much
foreign